let me take you to the trading floor a
few ticks in Woking where the man the US
authorities say triggered the 2010 flash
crash once worked Bloomberg's right
Chilcott has been speaking exclusively
to the chairman of the trading firm and
joins us from there now Ryan yeah but
we're on few taxes trading floor just
outside of London here you can see
there's about two dozen traders here
this morning most people start at about
7:00 a.m. and they carry on right until
the market that they're trading in
closes a little bit of a lull right now
I can actually see we're also on their
screens here the way it works is the
traders come here they pay a fee to
avail themselves of the resources to you
know sort of be part of the information
feed that's so important to markets they
also share some of their profits as you
said this is where no vendor sirot
worked between 2002 and 2008 you spent
the better part of his 20s here and it's
really where he learned to trade despite
the fact that it has been seven years
since he left he is still very revered
here if for no other reason that you
know he was a real top performer real
trading at real trading prowess I sat
down with the chairman one of the
cofounders of futex and asked him what
he thought about Newman dursa wrote
today have a listen I was always going
to be the kind of person that I believe
would be legendary potentially legendary
in some way in the in the future the
potential to be remembered has been one
of the world's great trades and he
certainly has been of his generation one
of the best to get a job at futex to
have one of these partnerships pretty
stringent application process so the
chairman was telling me that about one
out of 100 applications one maybe two
people that put in applications of the
companies that this company actually get
an interview and that out of the people
that interview maybe they hire one out
of ten even the vendor was even after
that selected he had a scholarships he
wasn't actually paying for the training
to to improve his trading skills when he
was here you're tested effectively on
three things on your math on your
psychological traits and also on your
passion and he came through with flying
colors on all three of those fronts one
thing that the Chairman remembers that
did distinguish him from most traders is
that in addition to being frugal he
seemed to be the kind of guy that was
you know accumulating money in his
trading account simply for the sake of
accumulating the money it didn't
actually seem to want to spend it which
is a big distinction from a lot of the
traders that get into this line of work
and finally you know Paulo Rosie
although obviously the trading that took
place after he left here in 2008 the
2009 to 2014 period that US prosecutors
are so interested in when we had the
flash crash in 2010 you know he wasn't
working here but nonetheless Paulo Rosie
doesn't think that he could
single-handedly cause a market crash
that he was behind the flash crash could
he have been a factor sure but the idea
that somebody trading out of their home
beneath the flight path you know I
ascend a detached house in Hounslow you
know here at least a few texts they
think that's pretty laughable all right
interesting Ryan
great great great exclusive interview
around Chilcote there